all right now to Washington where the
Federal Reserve meets this week to
consider another interest rate hike to
tackle High inflation now you may
already be stretching your wallet to buy
gifts for your family and friends and
Scott McFarland is going to show us how
the high cost of Christmas is hitting
Americans in other ways too
Christmas tree farmer Gary Thomas who's
chopping and selling trees he planted
eight years ago at his sprawling
operation near the Pennsylvania Maryland
border that's how long it takes to grow
trees tall enough for people's living
rooms I need to get Heights people want
you know eight foot Thomas says when the
trees went in the ground he had no idea
how expensive business would be this
Christmas
because he needs to pay more to keep
workers in a competitive labor market
and his Supply prices are Spike
fertilizer costs more the chemicals cost
more how do you not pass these costs
along to the customer well unfortunately
we've had to so my prices went up 15
this year on Fraser fur Thomas is
charging more than 100 each for his
finest trees it's scary
when I went to this year's price I
thought how much resistance am I going
to get how many complaints am I going to
get how many Google reviews are going to
say I charge too much
decoration costs are rising too Kathy
Brown operates a 12 month a year
Christmas store in St Michael's Maryland
where there are always ornaments and
decorations for sale but where it's
never been more complicated to actually
set a price our shipping costs impacting
you very much surcharges and fuel costs
make it pricier to bring the merchandise
in and then to send it out she'll take a
hit this holiday I might not make it as
much as it needs to be for my regular
pricing I'll absorb that cost for now
and when it comes to holiday dinner
there's sticker shock there as well with
key Staples up between 15 and 25 percent
but despite inflation pressures the
national retail Federation is still
bullish they're expecting holiday sales
could jump eight percent from last year
more than 900 billion dollars after two
holidays disrupted by covid and supply
chain crises everything's gone up and
it's not just you know what you're going
to get for the gifts it's food it's
operations it's all the stuff to
decorate with and it goes quick for
Karen Hilton she'll cut back on other
holiday expenses but not on gifts thank
you so much especially for her
five-year-old granddaughter Amelia no
I'd rather not get something than not
get her something
these industries have challenges but
they also have jobs there is a pressing
need for seasonal workers and they have
one built-in Advantage it's the holidays
people are not willing to sacrifice
tradition Nate
Scott you might want to take a picture
right there with that tree behind you
looks like a holiday card man it really
does a lot of ornaments on there can't
get another one on that's packed I'll
have a good one Scott